now the longer I do comedy the more I'm
starting to see that I think jealousy is
just a part of comedy and Colin goes
what's your last name
I go Souter he goes uh change it
finishing finishing your closing bit
while half the room is leaving is one of
the most humbling experiences anyone can
go through when you're like and then I
said I am like that that's not a
parachute and people are walking thank
you everyone
all right hot breath averse welcome back
to the hot breath podcast this is the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros this is our live Q&A series if
you're watching this on YouTube or
listening to the podcast later go join
our Facebook group it's free there's
comics from around the world in there
connecting and engaging and getting
access to some of the top comedy minds
in the world and without any exception
our guest definitely ranks on that so
without further ado ladies and gentlemen
hop brother and sister and welcome to
the hot breath averse mr. Dan Soder
ladies and gentlemen Dan Soder
hey what's up hello digital people hello
not being able to hear applause it's
creepy as hell there was a sound effect
if that makes you feel any better that
makes me feel much better I didn't hear
it so I didn't get the fake out the fake
adulation so I get that the fake bump
the fake spike in adrenaline oh but you
will get the hot breath bump I will say
after mark Normand did his first hopper
episode a few years ago his career just
took off so I think this may be your big
break Dan I knew this was the fuel in
Norman's tank I [ __ ] knew it
at first I was like is it because he
writes such great jokes and he's a great
comic I'm like nope he's got that hot
bread he got that hot breath rub so what
we can do actually because I was gonna
start with with the quarantine situation
and all this but we were talking off air
we'll just jump in to what we were
talking about with the comedy show that
we just saw happen in New York and
you're jealous see I think you said
you're feeling very
the media immediately jealous eye I saw
wash I woke up I think it was yesterday
and my girlfriend was on Instagram and
she's like oh did you see they did a
that Michael Chan at a comedy show and I
was like yeah I heard he was gonna do
that and then I saw pictures and
immediately was like man a fur it's it's
so funny like the insecurity of a
comedian or just my insecurities I can't
speak for everyone but immediately I was
like oh I want to do stand up right now
and then number two I was like oh man I
didn't get booked on that show and
you're like did you change like he did
like a show in the back of a flatbed in
Long Island City and the lineup was
awesome it was PD rosebud Baker nimesh
there was a lot of fun comics on that
and then big Jay and Joe DeRosa went up
with Jay and like hung out and made and
like you know talk [ __ ] and that was
also why I was jealous like man that'd
be so fun just to be honestly I don't
know if I'm jealous for the stage time
or if I'm jealous just to be around
people making other people laugh I think
that's something that I I really [ __ ]
miss that's interesting even hearing
someone like 15 years in with you you
just released the HBO special have done
so many awesome things and yet you're
still in this you still have that
impulse that I think every comic has
where we're like oh I didn't get booked
on that yeah every year see yeah every
list every show everything I think I'm
interested to see like you know I've
heard before in comedy like a 10 years
you kind of figure out what you're doing
at 15 years you kind of hone it more at
20 you get to that next level or
whatever and I was like when is it where
you don't care if you're not on a lineup
that's good what is it what year is it
where you're like you're like coming up
it's the new lineup at cluster fest
which I didn't even want to do and I was
like man I didn't ask me exactly they
didn't even have to be a good thing it
could be a shitty thing whether like
we're doing barnyard comedy just for
horses and you're like no I didn't what
did they book me a flyer there's
automatic jealousy regardless of the
show yeah yeah I think
the longer I do comedy the more I'm
starting to see that I think jealousy is
just a part of comedy I think it's like
not necessarily in just a negative way I
think I don't know I always get jealous
when I see people with bits that I'm
like man I wish I would have thought of
that I think that's I don't think that
goes away I hope it doesn't go away or
else you're gonna I'm gonna be a
sociopath just not caring about jokes
but yeah I think jealousies a part of
stand-up and I think I would have liked
to have known that earlier on have you
found any ways to at least kind of
alleviate some jealousy over more minut
things as opposed to like maybe a bigger
thing now I've noticed with jealousy
it's always jealousy or negativity is
most of the time just something that you
have a problem with yourself so like
what I'm jealous about that kind of
stuff I'm like well maybe I should go
work harder maybe I should just shut up
and go write more or go do more sets or
try to have better sets or you know
that's always the way I've been where
I'm just kind of like anytime I've
gotten and and by the way it doesn't
always come from like a very like oh I'm
gonna be better sometimes it comes
straight up from a spiteful like well
I'm gonna go do sets let's see how you
guys like me in five years when I say no
I won't be on that show like and then
the next week they're like hey do you
wanna do my show I would love to oh look
I do the show okay yeah I'll check my
calendar but we'll see well I can I have
insulin I had yeah I had a lot of that
coming up in New York where like I
wouldn't I wouldn't get put on the cool
shows and I would be like well [ __ ] you
then I'm gonna go do my own thing and
then they don't you wanna do the show
and I would that would be great and then
you're like yeah it's it's it's funny
man
I think I'm excited to be around
comedians again yeah decided to be here
I'm excited about it to be around comedy
again I'm getting excited what kind of
tips do you have for comics going
through the current quarantine because a
big thing a topic that's come up in our
community has been like Oh on we know
when we get back on stage I'm starting
to like fene for
or whatever but it's like what what
advice do you have for comics on like
how they can maximize the time they have
away from the stage to propel their
career so when the stage comes back like
they're hitting the ground running I
don't know man because I've thought
about it a lot even a conversation to
have my mom where she was like if this
would happened to you ten years ago
you'd have to move back to Denver and I
was like yeah absolutely I would
absolutely have to move I'm [ __ ] if this
happened in 2013 or 2014 I would I had
to move back to Denver so there's this
real thing of I kind of feel for comics
coming up right now because their
fragility of it it was just exposed
where it's just completely taken away
and there probably were a lot of
comedians that were making progress not
only professionally but personally in
comedy like that there's there's moments
and it's you know I remember when I was
first starting and I would watch like
Last Comic Standing or crowd and listen
to Opie and Anthony and I always
remember the the advice was always the
same it was like get on stage as much as
you can and I always thought was like I
thought that advice was kind of boring
but now I've said this before but I mean
it I think it's the same as when someone
is like how do I lose weight and they're
like diet and exercise and you're like
no no no like how do I really lose
weight you know like diet exercise it's
just a commitment and the thing about
stand-up is I don't I can't tell you
when I've turned corners because it's
just doing stand-up every night all of a
sudden on Monday you are away a better
comedian than you were last Wednesday
and you don't know which said it was
that made you realize like oh yeah if I
do this that works or I can I can say
this and get away with it and it's funny
I can't say that and get away with it so
my best advice for comedians going
through this right now because I hope
we're at the tail end of it but I also
don't know would be try to find a way to
scratch that itch without being able to
do stand-up if you can do that via Zoom
shows or you know online shows I would
say do that I don't know
to Sara Lee like them but I'm lucky
enough that I can wait for audiences to
come back but I would also say you don't
have to release everything you do I
think we're in this weird age where
everyone wants to show you how busy they
are without actually concentrating on
making something that's really good so
you know before big Jay and I got the
bonfire we were gonna do it as a podcast
and we did ten episodes that we never
released they're just 10 hours of Jana
and I sitting in my living room trying
stuff you know what the first three
hours were us sitting down and the
energy was real low and then I had music
and there was we made an agreement to
stand up during the entire time and then
that became like we kind of shifted with
the energy and then by the time we were
able to have the opportunity to do the
bonfire on Sirius XM we kind of already
knew what it what our dynamic was and I
think with the reason I'm saying this is
like comedians you can you can go and
talk like this like I could talk to my
computer and then I could watch it and
you could watch it be like oh that's
funny
or you could do a podcast and just do
ten episodes by yourself or find a theme
and work it out it's like there's a lot
to be said about working something out
for sure and just that repetition and
like you thought about working something
out for your special your newest one
like you not only worked out here in
America but then you went to like
Ireland and then you went to like
Scotland like you wanted to make sure
this thing was airtight from every
single angle it'll work it out yeah I
wanted to make sure that people who get
sunburned easily loved that hour that
was the whole point of that to her just
like let me go to the whitest freckly
assess on earth and work these jokes now
I was opera I was really lucky to be
able to do the Fringe Festival which
unfortunately isn't happening this year
because of kovin but it was it was a
great opportunity like you said for
repetition and it felt as someone that
played high school football I wasn't
good at it but I always loved football
it felt like going to a football camp
where it was like oh I get to I have
part of the day to do Edinburgh stuff
walk around get a coffee hang out with
Sean
Pattin I was really lucky to live with
him in in Geoffrey Baldinger and Caitlyn
cook and it was like a good house to
live in because it's three other people
doing shows but also just three people
that I I got to live with and in in know
better
but it was the best thing possible
anyone that's doing an hour whether it
be an album or a special I can't
recommend doing the Fringe Festival more
because it's just you go through an
entire process of learning failing
rebuilding leaving strong Michelle wolf
told me while I was there she's like
when you get back to America you're
gonna feel like a [ __ ] super like you
have superpowers because you've just
been doing it every night for an hour
and the first show I did back was like
was the Kevin Barnett benefit at
Brooklyn Steel and it just felt like oh
I'll just they were like do eight
minutes and I was like cool I have this
chunk and I just like took it out of the
hour and was like damn this thing is
tight like you don't realize how tight
the bid is until you do it and you know
I unfairly I was I was on it was a
benefit show with a stacked lineup but
it was people doing like this guy doing
you know and I came in like like this
[ __ ] line into this line and it can
and knew when to let it breathe and [ __ ]
and that was all that was all Fringe
Festival so yeah I think with the last
hour it was all about repetition and and
I we agreed to do the special in
December of 2018 and then I filmed it at
October of 2019 telling HBO like hey
give me ten months to go I had the hour
I mean I would probably say what came
out on the special was 45 percent when I
sold it what they saw originally and I
had you know I have other bits that
hopefully work when I go back on the
road I don't know I don't even know if I
know how to do [ __ ] jokes anymore but
not less I've had dreams about it man
I've been having dreams where I'm on
stage and I don't know how to finish
bits where I'm like
okay carpenters huh it's like okay guy
could be Jesus and then he's like
non-union but it's it's a thing where I
missed the repetition I miss the you
know I was I was watching my girlfriend
play with our dog yesterday at like 6:45
and I told her this morning I was like
that's gonna be weird when I'm like at
the bonfire at 6:45 and then I have to
be like oh I got a 8:45 at the stand in
a 935 at the cellar and during this
whole time it was like me living at home
just being like what should we have for
dinner tonight
mother you know what when it comes to
actually generating material because
that is something I think comics are
even if we're writing right now it's
like who knows when I'm gonna get on
stage who knows we're gonna remember it
who knows if I'm gonna care back then
but something I heard I've heard you say
they really helped you is when you
started trying to make yourself laugh
instead of trying to make other people
laugh could you kind of expand on that
and maybe give advice for how comics can
start to shift their mindset in that
direction goddamn dude you're nailing it
I just got out of a therapy session
where we talked about all of this and it
was a thing of you know I I have a
desperate need to be liked I think all
comedians do I think that's why we have
to stand up on stage and ask for the
affection of strangers but I also think
it comes in different shades and I think
some people like nagging an audience and
pushing at them and being like huh
[ __ ] but you still like me like Shane
Gillis is the best I've ever seen at
that
like Shane Gillis is the best at being
like you guys are gay and they're like I
love you you know but he's like doing it
in like in like a a warm older brother
kind of way where he can like he's given
you a noogie on your head you know he's
like come here you piece of [ __ ] and
you're like I love you oh do you wanna
talk about
and then there's guys like you know big
J has like this incredible just outside
guy smoking a cigarette energy you know
he has like a real like crazy was going
on huh and you're like yeah and then the
next
you know you're explaining your
ex-girlfriends [ __ ] to him yeah how
did I get into this how did I get into
this and I think mine was like the way I
was raised I grew up really afraid of my
mom because I think she was stressed out
and just kind of you know I was a very
fearful child I was very if I was alone
I was the only child and I was my mom
was working all the time so I was alone
and then when she would bring in was
like fear of whether it be
disappointment or you [ __ ] up or you
didn't do these right so I think my
first [ __ ] 10 years of comedy was
just me being like hey hey you were cool
right it's cool and then the last five
years has been an eventual evolution of
me trying to be like oh yeah I'm my
sense of humor is why I'm here like me
the jokes I'm making my head I've set
him out loud enough and had I've paid
enough taxes to know that that's a
viable career now the question is like
am i doing it am i doing jokes that I
would want to watch and that's a real
that's a real hard question because I
don't like the HBO special I think I put
so much work into it I was proud of it
as a body of work and I was really proud
that's the most proud of anything I've
ever done that's like I almost get this
like weird offense when people are like
hey check out his Netflix half-hour I'm
like don't do that that was a half-baked
piece of [ __ ] that was me trying to
recoup for putting out an hour on Comedy
Central that didn't go the way I wanted
it to but this HBO special is really the
first thing that I've watched or what we
you know when I was editing it I've
never watched it after edited it but
where I watched it I'm like yeah these
bits are completed like they're
completed I and that's something I have
to thank Fringe for I went all the way
through the bit and when you go all the
way through it and it's like a great
book that people should read of
comedians should read that helps with
comedy I think and I'm about to reread
it is how to win an argument by Cicero
it's this book that I found you know in
a bookstore being a pretentious dickwad
but I found this book and I was like
this is he was a lawyer who had to not
only represent his friends but his
enemies and he's like one of the
greatest arguers I don't even use the
word but he's like one of the greatest
[ __ ] talkers of all time and he lays it
out so it's a very short read but it's
it's something that in it something in
it really I read it before I did fringe
it made me I kept thinking about this
during the Fringe Festival which was
like when you have an idea cast a very
wide net so that when you pull it back
you've gone through everything so when
you have an idea like has the widest net
possible to see what you can catch in it
and then when you pull it all back in
you'll have you'll know you went
everywhere with the idea so where you
settle will be the best idea I think he
says it better than that and the idea
might be a little different but point
being is like with a premise I want to
start working on like I always loved
watching guys like Kurt Metzger because
Kurt Metzger was a guy where I'm like
man that angle on that joke is unique
and perfect in a way that no one else is
gonna do that angle Nate Nate bargatze
unbelievable with that Nate part gets
these unbelievable at finding those and
things that are just as simple as like
grape jelly you know if I say like grape
jet like I've had several conversations
on the phone with Nate we're in
conversation he said something whether
it be about buying a tiger or whether it
being about having ketchup in your
refrigerator at the time it was grape
jelly and he changed it to catch up but
then I watch his stand up and be like my
god he's got four different angles on
that that maybe we didn't have in the
conversation but that he's built into
this that are just genius it's just so
funny and I really love that about all
my friends you know a guy like Becky own
who can do a mega bus bit where if I
told you there's a mega bus bit you'd be
like I don't know if I can listen to 15
minutes of that but then you see Becky
owns and it's layered and it's nuanced
and it's really funny and I always I
always really love those kind of jokes
well this actually ties into our first
question when we're talking about joke
writing because I mean you being able to
tackle dark humor in the way you do and
the topics you do is I mean inspiring to
all of us comics and showing what's
possible within comedy writing and
Christian Williams actually he actually
messaged me this morning saying how
excited he was about this so he actually
got here early the first question
so [ __ ] you dude thanks Christian so his
question he says a crackle crackle Dan
yeah goddamn right so how do you find
ways to turn difficult personal matters
into good comedy like your joke and
material about your dad man well that's
like something that Jay and I have
talked about on the bonfire before is
like styles of comedy where new comics
try to be like a Doug Stanhope
and you're like you can't be Doug
Stanhope Doug Stanhope is one of the
greatest of all time and I built that
naturally Bill Hicks was Bill Hicks and
that's it like you're not gonna walk in
and be one of these guys it's like
trying to you know I look at it as like
fixing an engine and it's like you got
to learn how to build simpler engines
before you get to a highly complex one
like you can't just walk in and build
you know a six cylinder where you're
like I know exactly how this runs you
got to build a little [ __ ] go-cart
engine and then a dirt you know you got
to learn as you build up and I I wish I
could've started comedy with that joke
about my dead dad but it took me you
know 15 years to find out okay what's
the angle where it's I can show everyone
that I think the situation is funny
because I'm noticing the people that get
offended when I first started doing it
were people that had no skin in the game
it was people that had both living
parents and they were kind of like oh
god that's kind of sad and you're like
whoa why why is it sad your parents not
dead my parents did like I'm talking
about my thing and really I just wanted
to get to make fun of my dad for being a
Jimmy Buffett fan that was really like
no because that was something where it
was
like I didn't realize my dad was a hack
alcoholic until the bonfire and big J
was like dude yeah like Jimmy Buffett
fans he's like that's funny and I was
like it is really funny and he loves
Jimmy Buffett it's like sincere just
like finding out that I was a bar kid
and that's like a bad thing it's like I
don't think point being is like with
dark humor it goes back to what we were
talking about earlier what you find
funny about it and then it's it's like
how you find something funny and how
other people can come to it and
understand that you find it funny so
it's not a big deal I guess is my way of
saying that it's like getting into dark
humor is first off it's the genuine
reaction I have to anything sad in my
life is to immediately mock it
immediately mock it um almost every time
something bad has happened to me in my
life I think I've gone to humor is just
being like well this [ __ ] sucks
because I don't I've never understood
the people that whale in it you know I
there'll be time to there'll be time for
the pain but some people react different
and some people want to be sad and
wailing it and those people write songs
in write plays you know I think comics
are the ones that are like man [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] sucks so is that where that
bit started when you're like well I had
to find out what was funny to me first
so were you like I think it's funny he
was a Jimmy Buffett fan now let me find
all the different angles into it exactly
my my initial premise was like uh my dad
was a Jimmy Buffett fan and that's
hilarious that he died of alcoholism
like my initial premise was like my dad
got what he wanted
like Jimmy Buffett fans want to drink
themselves to death my dad did it
so like that's a good thing like I
really like taking negative things and
trying to do put them in a positive
light in a funny way not in a serious
way around those negative things pretty
good in a funny way like what if this
was good like what if this was a good
thing like that would be you know really
funny I think because whenever I see
stuff whether it be from the past or
something that's like completely wrong
and in the wrong light I always think
that's the funniest where I'm like how
did they think this was a good take like
they thought this was right and I I
think with jokes that's kind of what I
like that's how I like to find my angles
there's like okay well what would be the
flip side how would I how would I find
this to be funny this is bad but what if
it wasn't and you start to build from
that yeah man I grew up with I grew up
with a mom that was like don't be a
[ __ ] yeah I mean like I grew up with a
mom that was like oh you're hurt okay
[ __ ] get up I mean this woman
survived like two major car accidents
Guillaume beret like she was like I
don't give a [ __ ] that you're sad now
granted that royally [ __ ] me on a lot
of other issues in life but as far as a
comedian it's like she put me on the
wheel and Conan like she was just like
push the [ __ ] wheel and then by the
time I got off it I was like I was
sitting there my mom is like Daniel what
is best in life I like to make fun of
everything that hurts and turn it into
punchlines to destroy enemies and I mean
that was like with my mom basically she
put me on the wheel dude only a comedian
is like all that emotional abuse a pet
prepared me to be a great comic yes I
mean yo man there was a reason that they
let men [ __ ] children in Sparta because
it made them into good soldiers they're
like I love this man he took care of me
it's I [ __ ] up when you read like
Spartan history because we glory we
glorify like Sparta is like they were
the greatest warriors it's like duty
raped kids in order to [ __ ] establish
a connection like it's [ __ ] up but
it's also that to me is the kind of
thing where I think that's funny where
I'm like it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
that we allowed such an atrocity for
something that like oh it's cool there
were such good warriors it's like you
know much dirt they did to get there
yeah exactly dude if you're gonna wear a
cape you're gonna end up raping some
kids you know that's just how it is
shirtless cape all right let's get the
next one in here see how we can segue
off of
let's come off Spartan but race so this
comes from chase Bannen here he says it
seems you and a lot of your friends are
getting a lot of recognition like Joe
list mark Normand Sean Patton are there
any other comics you recommend we follow
that are on your level but may have not
had the exposure and do you float ideas
around with other comics when writing
yeah all the time in all the time Mike
Becky owned is one of the I mean he's my
roommate
and he's a guy who's been on here that I
float he I I'm I'm living with my
girlfriend now and we're making the step
towards both of us are gonna split up
you know Becky and I have lived together
for [ __ ] the eight or nine years and
he was the go-to he was the go-to of
like hey has anyone done this bit and
then you're like yeah so-and-so has a
bit that's kind of similar and then
you're like alright let me drop the
premise but you know Michelle wolf and
Nate and Shane Gillis are probably the
people I call the most with like hey is
anyone do this or is like is this funny
you just need that one you just need
that one sentence where you're like hey
is this sentence funny and then they're
like yeah and then you won't you have to
be like a little truffle pig and [ __ ]
dig into that sentence and be like how
deep how deep does this go and I think
I'm very lucky because the people that I
am friends with are some of the best in
comedy talent-wise
I think they're I think it's all all my
friends were top tier and uh you know
Sean Patton would be the name that I
would say check him out because I think
he is criminally underrated and I think
he's criminally underrated I think Chloe
Hilliard is really [ __ ] funny and I
think people should check her out I'm
trying to think of who else is you know
Norman and list watching them blow up
those are guys I Dan st. Germain dan st.
remains a guy where I'm like he's so
goddamn funny like I watched like a
minute of them and I'm like he's just
he's the beard and the hair but it's
more than that it's it's the way that
Dan was a guy who we came up together
when I would watch him I would get
jealous of this joke
like I remember I watched him at South
by Southwest do this he's like there's
Papa John's Pizza but there's never step
Papa John's Pizza you know like like the
pizzas not as good he's like hey man I
know we don't get along but I love your
mom I remember watching that and being
like dude he's so goddamn funny but
there are there's like there's a ton of
comics out there and and I think that's
this this is a great time for comedy
even though it's shut down because
there's so many avenues where people can
explore and learn about comedians great
yeah a lot of good yeah there's so much
comedy right now and I remember Dan st.
Germain's one of those guys who like
he's he writes on a lot of shows and
things like that right yeah so it's like
yeah yeah it's kind of like in Ian
Edwards who we've had on here it's like
he's super funny but he's been in that
writing world that can kind of conflict
with getting that stand-up exposure
absolutely one of the funniest people I
think that I've ever seen in my life
Luke Cunningham was a great stand-up
comedian and got started writing and
then walked away from stand-up well I
you know I don't know if it was a good
or bad thing but he was a guy where I
would watch him do stand-up and then he
be like yeah I can't really do it that
much I got to go right now my god dammit
here your stand-up is so [ __ ] funny
and yeah it's just there's there's
people like that
there's just people that that you know
comedy is a business and a part of this
business is traveling and if you're
gonna do stand-up you have to be willing
to be gone Thursday through Sunday most
of your life living in a hotel room but
if you love comedy enough and you have a
video game system and some decent weed
you know not a bad weekend oh you're a
beacon of inspiration for all of us
that's smoke we play video game yeah and
the next one is from Lee Hudson who's
actually he's from across the pond
actually so yeah I feel like I've met
Lee before man sounds familiar I don't
know man again I smoke weed and play
video games
it could have been a [ __ ] created
character or something I don't know but
yeah we yeah we have comics all over the
world that tune into this so he he asks
what what is it like working with Chris
store to shoot your special man he was
great Chris door [ __ ] nailed it I you
know I I think I'm in this weird part of
my life where I'm learning how to speak
up for what I want creatively which i
think is a weird timing because it's
kind of like you know I think in general
white guys need to do less public
squawking and do more listening but then
like creatively it's weird because it's
like oh yeah I've learned that if I
don't say what I want the thing that I'm
gonna make isn't gonna be what I want
and that's a hard thing is to go through
the process of making something and
being like I would have done it a little
bit different I loved the way that my
our special for Comedy Central not
special was filmed Marcos libera libera
[ __ ] [ __ ] up his last name Marcus
and the guys there did a great job
shooting it Chris store came in and I
had to have a conversation with him
where I was like mmm this is exactly
what I want
I want a loaf I know audience I want an
old I want an old school feel to a
stand-up special I felt like everyone
now was doing shiny and bright in like
big words and me on and you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] scared look how big this
[ __ ] stage is oh my god you can't
cover it in an hour and I wanted to do
something that was like yeah man here's
me in the pocket just [ __ ] firing
jokes off and here's an hour of like I
didn't want one moment of fat I wanted
it cut I wanted it in there and I told
Chris I was like I want you to film it
in a specific way and he said yes and I
believed him and then when we did tech
scout and all that [ __ ] and I showed up
the day of the special and he showed me
what the cameras look like I was like
[ __ ] a dude you did it
you did the exact thing I wanted you
know and he's like and it's great to be
like to have surprises where they did it
they did a shot in the special where it
was my back so it's the spotlight and
then my back and then you can barely see
the audience around it but I loved that
shot and that wasn't something I asked
for that was just something that he did
and Chris is a guy that he understands
what the [ __ ] you're trying to get and
so he was really super easy to work with
because it was a thing of like oh man
you you're hearing what I'm saying and
that makes me think this is gonna come
out the way it did and then when I
watched the first cut watching a cut of
a special is really [ __ ] difficult
because you can't I've learned when
editing a special listen to it first
then wash it because if you're trying to
listen and watch you're gonna get lost
and like hand movements and [ __ ] like
that
and I listened to the HBO special and I
was like yeah that's that's what I
wanted
that's the hour and then I watched it
and I was so pleasantly surprised of
like oh [ __ ] man this guy [ __ ] did it
this guy made this into the thing I
wanted to
let's take you off your high horse here
and let's take you back to your worst
bomb this is kind of like a combo
question of Mattias Segal and John
Rousseau's both are asking bombing
questions but let's go with one is like
remember the first time you bombed but
maybe like maybe your biggest bomb and
how it felt well first just cuz I know
off the top of my head the first like
real bad bomb that I had was at an open
mic at laughs in Tucson and it was a
three-minute spot and I went up there
and I hadn't really gotten into writing
outsets
I kind of had ideas and was like when I
get up there I'll just fall through the
idea also Marcus Raboy
I just remembered his name and I feel
like a date yeah okay is he okay
I remember going on the heat I remember
exactly what I was wearing
I remember her premises that went
nowhere and then I would bail and go to
another premise that went nowhere so
it'd be like you guys uh hey you guys
ever go to the grocery store and you
like you like I went on a date I was
trying to go on a date in this girl and
it was like that dude for it was a
three-minute set it's the one of the
only times in my life I've ever bailed
it's one of my only times my life I've
ever bailed from the stage and I had
gone off at a minute it was [ __ ]
brutal dude I went to the back of that
comedy club and this is when you can
still smoke cigarettes inside and I
smoked a half a pack of cigarettes with
my head in between my legs like I was
just like smoking just like oh my god
that sucked so [ __ ] bad and then
probably the biggest bomb that I've had
is I don't know man they've they've all
I'm bombed a lot at the Caroline's I've
had a couple hot ones yeah dude I took I
took two tough ones back-to-back on New
Year's Eve New Year's Eve is a rough
night for stand-up everyone every comic
knows that when you do Caroline's New
Year's Eve you're in Times Square and
part of the cell of the ticket to the
comedy show cuz it's not a major
headliner it's like Caroline's used to
do it where it's like five really good
New York stand-up comics so you get like
five like up-and-coming guys or girls or
whoever and you would you would do the
shows and then the appeal was at 11:45
or 11:50 you go upstairs
and you get to watch the ball drop and
then you get to go right back inside and
have drinks and celebrate the new year I
did it the first time I did it I was
drinking and it was like I was like
second on the show and it was fun I was
like [ __ ] Harry there's Joe DeRosa
was
shows with me and drinking and smoking
cigarettes and in the green room and it
was just a [ __ ] party the second time
I did it I had my girlfriend with me I
was sober for a year and it was New
Year's Eve and they had me go last on
both shows first show there today they
just [ __ ] they don't care they're
just there to do it
I used the bit every New Year's but it's
still true and it was birthed from that
where I was like how the [ __ ] are y'all
judging me when you're wearing plastic
top hats you're like wearing a fake
fancy thing and you're you think I'm not
funny [ __ ] you
that was like my first reaction the
second show was to this day I can
remember the feeling of that bomb of
like usually when you're bombing you can
get a joke and it's like oh there we go
I'm up I'm up I'm up out of it this one
was like oh no oh it was like falling
downstairs I was like that joke didn't
work that joke didn't work and then I
start getting peanut butter mouth and I
start sweating and then I'm like bad
joke didn't work that didn't work and
then I get to the end I'm doing 15
minutes it's only a 15 minute bomb and
by [ __ ] minute 12 I can losing the
audience hurts more than anything when
you've completely lost the audience and
they start talking to themselves because
then it's a subconscious effort from the
audience to be like I don't want to
listen to this [ __ ] idiot anymore I'd
rather talk to you and so I remember
losing them and then I remember all of
them starting to look at their watch and
being like it's 11:50 it's 11:50 they
like look at their phones back it's
11:50 we got to get in there like people
started to get up and walk to go oh dude
finishing finishing your closing bit
while half the room is leaving is one of
the most humbling experience does anyone
can go through when you're like and then
I said I am like that
that's not a parachute and people are
walking thank you everyone
[ __ ] and then you gotta walk up stairs
and celebrate New Year's with these
people to just watch you fail oh [ __ ]
that really that one that was the one
that was probably one of the worst bombs
because I remember my girlfriend being
like she was very like you know one of
those girls it's like god damn it that
was like grading on me because I was
like you just watched me eat [ __ ] how
are you this happy how are you not like
hey dude do you need a cigarette like
you want to sit down if I were my
girlfriend in that time when I bombed I
would have had an ice pack for the back
of my neck like like at the end of a new
japan pro wrestling match like when they
just put ice on like you took a lot of
bumps in there and you're like I know I
know [ __ ] hurt how are you how are
you able to I feel like I've been doing
comedy 10 years now and like I'm getting
better at bouncing back from bombs but I
mean you know they still yeah they still
suck like how have you how have you been
able to kind of alleviate the
repercussions of a bomb and kind of make
it less like daunting I don't know man
I think another set is the only cure yes
the only cure for a ball it's the only
thing that can pull you out is like a
good set cuz then you're like okay so I
don't so those people were wrong cuz
that's what you walk away from you're
like it was I wrong am I wrong to be in
this and then and then you and then you
have a good set and you're like oh no no
never mind they were wrong [ __ ] them
these guys right this audience gets it
those other [ __ ] dholtze didn't
understand what I was saying yeah so
it's there is no way and I think
honestly is bombing is the soreness in
comedic exercise it's like if you if
you're really sore then you need to work
out more you need to be up there more
and it's like it's always gonna there's
gonna be a soreness with it because
you're like man I've had mornings where
I've woken up and I've been like
goddammit that last show like I'll do
three shows at the stand and
first two I'll be like looks like I
found what I was born on this earth to
do and then the third shell would be
like hey should I kill myself by eating
my own [ __ ]
that last crowd couldn't have cared less
well it's good we're not alone in that
feeling nah man bomb but it's also a
necessity it's like a you know it's just
it's a part of the process I'm gonna
dude coming back I'm in st. Louis
June 25th through the 27th that first
show there are gonna be some misses I
don't it might not even be the first
show it might be like Friday Late Show
where I'm like what the [ __ ] am i doing
on stage well let's let's uh get to Leo
here cuz this is a good one from the
perspective of even like taking your
comment to the next level he asks Leo
Konopka he's asking is there more
benefit from starting my own mics and
Baltimore's like starting shows or
should he move to like one of the big
hubs he's like he's starting shows he's
hosting he's the door guy to place but
what's moved or moved to a big place
move okay my advice for anyone would be
get a year or two under your belt to
kind of understand how comedy feels in
whatever city you start in or wherever
city you live in spend about a year
learning the end you know low stakes man
go do open mics that that are stressful
as [ __ ] to you but when you look back 15
years later you go that wasn't [ __ ] so
go do those like it's you know at the
beginning of every video game where you
have the really first easy level and
it's just kind of there to teach you the
controls of the game that's what your
local scene is go do that level and run
run through it once or twice and then
move the difficulty too hard and move to
a hub move to New York or LA or Chicago
or a city where you're gonna be around
people that scare you and make you feel
wrong that you're doing this but also
there's a weird inspiration of like
catch up to you guys all I'll make it
I'll get to you where you guys are at
because that's something that I couldn't
have you know just pure idiot luck going
from Tucson where it's two years of you
know I had laughs which was a real Club
but then there's casinos where I was
just bombing all the time I'm opening
for people in casinos two small weird
shows that weren't really around I think
around much more now but then moving to
New York at still a beginners level
where I you know I know a lot of guys
that are headline earners that moved to
New York and they're like I'm not
getting spots and it's like yeah because
you were up here in your city and now
you're down here in this city so if
you're rising up in your city it's
easier to come down a little to go back
up you know like take a step back to go
take five steps back to go [ __ ] a
million steps forward and I think it's
really daunting to move to a big city
but be comfortable with the I was
comfortable with the idea of like I'm
gonna be a waiter for however long it
takes for me to get to become a stand-up
comedian and then the uncomfortable part
of that wasn't the beginning it was when
I was starting to get sets and when I
was starting to get you know I got on
live at Gotham on Comedy Central and I
was like starting to open for like Bobby
Kelly and other people like that and it
was like oh I don't want to be a waiter
anymore I just want to be a comedian but
that was the difficult part because
you're like but I could see the light I
could be like I'm getting stuff and
there was really depressing mornings
where I was going in and setting up a
cafe at a Mexican restaurant being like
dude I [ __ ] killed it last night at
stand-up New York and now I'm gonna be
the you know these people's [ __ ] iced
tea [ __ ] for the next seven hours and
it's like [ __ ] this man [ __ ] this like
Colin Quinn said you I had a good set
and now I got a listen to a stockbroker
tell me that the margarita tastes weird
it's like [ __ ] you it tastes weird you
ordered the wrong tequila so it was like
a thing that's my advice for moving to a
big city as far as starting a shows I
don't recommend starting shows because
I've seen a lot of good comedians get
trapped into spot training where they're
good they're good enough to be on a show
but because they have
their show whoever runs the show that
they were gonna be on now wants to be on
their show so now you don't know am i
being booked cuz I'm funny or am I being
booked because I have something to give
this comedian and I think that's a
dangerous spot to be in and you moved to
New York being at like the mecca and
when we had Nate on here he talked about
coming up in New York and he had like
funny like Patrice O'Neal and like Bill
burr story do you have any just
unforgettable story being around like a
comedian like one of those two that you
just never forget and I can't describe
to you the feeling of like growing up
and I know a lot of comics will
immediately feel this but it's like
growing up such a big comedy fan in like
loving stand-up comedy enough that you
want to get into it and then you start
it's seeing people come off the TV
screen it's like people crawling out of
the TV the first time I saw Chris Rock
walking to stand up in New York to do a
spot I was like oh my god that's [ __ ]
that's it's like seeing one of the gods
you're just seeing one of the gods walk
by you and my like my holy [ __ ] moment
my first holy [ __ ] moment of like me and
I'm in New York and I'm doing stand-up
was I'm obsessed with the movie comedian
I'll probably watch it again this
weekend just because I brought it up but
the documentary is my favorite thing and
I don't even think Jerry's not my
favorite part of the documentary it's
Colin Quinn and the way Colin talks
about comedy is something that I've
always romanticized and and I think he's
one of the greatest of all time
and I became friends with Joe list and
we he was like let's go to the cellar
and have some beers and I was like yeah
alright and I was nervous as [ __ ] and we
went into the cellar and never went
around the table I just sat at the bar
Joe Louis and I were drinking we had
each had our own pitcher of beer pitcher
of beer and Colin was fat tom is like
overweight and Colin was wearing a red
hoodie and like red sweatpants or
whatever and he comes over and he puts
his arm around both of us at the bar and
he goes
do you guys see that bomb Angeles it's
like nah we're up here and he goes I
don't know what it is about athletic
wear but you always wear it when you're
the least in shape and it was just like
being Colin Quinn and I'm just like
dumbstruck I'm just like sitting there
like oh this is great
and then Joe list goes Colin this is my
friend Dan Soder he just moved here from
Colorado to be a comedian and Colin goes
what's your last name
I go Souter he goes change it Colin
Quinn just hooked me which growing up
listening to Opie and Anthony and being
a big fan of Patrice and Burr and and
Colin and those guys in Jim Norton it
was like man like becoming being able to
text Jim Norton to me is [ __ ] insane
it's [ __ ] insane to be like oh if I
need to reach out I can just text Jim
Norton just like a Bobby Kelly being
like an older brother to me when the
quarantine first started my girlfriend
and I were re watching the wire and we
got born one night and she was like yeah
I'm gonna read I don't want to watch TV
and I went and watched tourgasm I like a
Linton watched it because I remember
when it came out and now it's so weird
to know Bobby as well as I know him and
to see that and you're like I remember
when that came out and like you know
Goldman and Bobby were like these guys
that you just didn't walk up and talk to
him and now I can like call Bobby and
Bobby you'll be like why don't you
[ __ ] call me early it did so
resulting yeah it's also in the same
sense it's been [ __ ] awesome watching
my friends become big like it's been
great watching Nate go into theatres and
become like one of the best working
stand-up comedians it's been great
watching Michelle wolf just become this
undeniable beast of a comedian you know
and just being like oh man all my
friends like a really good Michael che
like watching him become like even
bigger like we were so we started the
show talking about that show but the
fact that she can just without really a
lot of social media just put it out
there like yo man I want to do a show
and then like a thousand people show up
outside it's like man that's so great
and just knowing that how funny
and how funny Michelle and Nate are it's
just cool watching it start to pay off
well thank you so much for being so
generous with your time here Dan this
has been great yeah I love talking
comedy so I really appreciate you having
me on of course
yeah and all of those people you named
they're more than likely and open to
coming on this show please if you want
to text Jim Norton right now or you want
to call that I don't know if I have that
warm use podcast you'd be like [ __ ] even
wolf who's one of my best friends I bet
you a news podcaster check how do you
know I'm what do you I am did he know
you and you were a drunk yeah did you
say the wrong thing around him like I
don't know I don't [ __ ] know Michelle
hilarious yeah all those people are
definitely like we're trying to do
something positive you know for we're
trying to make comedy more accessible
but also we're creating more like
respect around the craft and getting to
interview people like you I think
comedians learn a lot but I think comedy
fans also create a new appreciation for
just what goes into not only the art but
the lifestyle like you said you've
really got to want it and a lot of
people don't understand that and doing
interviews like this I think help people
to create more appreciation around
comedy I did well I I appreciate you
having interviews like that because it's
comedy something that I [ __ ] love and
it's something that I've greatly missed
and it's something that I'm glad is
slowly starting to return and yeah
comedians are the best people on earth I
think they're I think they're incredibly
powerfully powerfully fragile and
wonderfully broken and I think that's
like the the best way to put it it's
like powerful powerfully fragile and
wonderfully broken it's like I all my
friends are man if I worked at an office
with I might have a real problem with
them but uh being comedians with them
makes me love them more than anyone on
earth and we always like to end this
show like with your closing advice for
comics whether it's a favorite tip
you've picked up along the journey or
just something
you've learned along your way do you
have any like closing advice or insight
for comedians out there yeah I
understand this is specifically for
comedians
is understand that the the people that
work at those comedy clubs might not be
the biggest comedy fans but they're the
most important because just as easily is
without us they're just a room with
tables and booze without them were just
crazy people yelling under a bridge so
be decent to every venue manager even if
they're a dick just be decent to them
unless they're like [ __ ] you know
like sexist or trying to rape you or
being racist or some [ __ ] like then [ __ ]
them
but I'm saying no that like most of the
server's there this wasn't their first
option to work at a [ __ ] funny bone
you know what I mean there's some people
that are but there's a lot of people
that are like I got hired at the funny
bone I'm kind of a fan of stand-up be
cool to them because you might make
their shitty Friday night better if
you're a little nice to them and then
they find you funny then they're not
waiting tables they're listening to you
headline twice and I always like that I
always like when waiters are like dude
thanks thanks for this weekend it was
like fun to work during this weekend and
you're like how [ __ ] yes man that's it
that's all we are is just the [ __ ]
lube so just you know Lube em up baby
yeah be not tip them as well don't
forget to tip them yeah that's part of
it yeah tip them take care of them yes
and they'll take care of you their
co-worker like you're all co-workers a
lot of people overlook that but you're
all coworker at this establishment be a
good coworker to them that's probably
the most distinct way I could that can
be said you you work with these people
be decent be decent to be around your
you're not that more you're not that
much more special than them just a
couple things broke right for you and
that's why you're on that side of it so
is there anything you want to promote or
how do people follow you wanna that I
got I just found out we haven't made the
official announcement but we're gonna
put out the HBO special son of a Gary
has an album in a couple weeks so if you
haven't heard it be on the lookout for
that that hour is coming out there's
also the full hour of not special is on
YouTube you can go watch that and also
listen to the bonfire Monday through
Thursday 6 to 8 p.m. Eastern on Comedy
Central radio Sirius XM it's a lot of
fun and if you can't pay for the
subscription get it elsewhere awesome
well hop read the verse Dan Soder give
it give it up for Dan Soder here Wow
listen to that that was the that's the
first clap I've gotten in months man
that felt good all right hop Brett the
verse
go forth with your days go join our
Facebook group to get involved in more
of these q A's and we will see you next
time on hot breath hey hot brother and
sister if you love comedy as much as we
do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips